que julie garnier oratrice la nationale
de la france
insoumise bonjour merci de répondre à
nos questions alexis corbière de la
france insoumise déclare que ce
changement de premier ministre ne
changera rien les mêmes causes
produiront les mêmes effets je suppose
que c'est votre avis tout simplement
parce qu'ils emmanuel macron a déjà
donné la feuille de route
il a déjà annoncé que la rentrée serait
difficile il a déjà annoncé qu'il ne
reviendrait pas sur la réforme des
retraites il a déjà annoncé que la
réforme du chômage serait poursuivi il a
déjà annoncé qu'il voulait revenir sur
les 35 heures je serai là on passait
très bien
il nous dit qu'on va avoir une une
rentrée difficile
donc voilà tout est dit vous parlez de
la réforme des retraites il annonce un
ce matin dans la presse quotidienne
régionale qui va y avoir de nouvelles
concertations avec les partenaires
sociaux même si le projet n'est pas
abandonné
oui bien sûr je vous l'avais dit toute
façon c'est très bien des recueils
trajectoire et nous dresse on sait très
bien que la vraie guerre va commencer à
la rentrée si une guerre qui sera mené
contre les travailleurs qu'on trouve les
classes populaires on sait très bien ce
qu'il veut faire
on n'est absolument pas dupes de ce
remaniement que juste de la
communication et de la vie politique
dont franchement on n'a pas vraiment
besoin
surtout quand on a un taux d'abstention
si élevé je crois que les français
attendent autre chose est sûre tous sont
inquiets ils sont inquiets parce qu'il
voit qu'il ya une grande vague de
licenciements qui se prépare qui est
déjà opérationnel et j'ai d'ailleurs une
pensée aujourd'hui pour tous les
salariés d'air france qui apprennent
qu'il ya cette année 600 suppressions
d'emplois alors qu'on a un gouvernement
qui offre 7 milliard à la même compagnie
sans aucune contrepartie
donc voilà la politique est déjà fait ça
sera toujours la même et effectivement
comme le dit alexis corbière
les mêmes causes produiront toujours les
mêmes effets
on voit en même temps sur sur ces images
les différentes pistes ont évoqué ce
matin par emmanuel macron pour la suite
de son quinquennat notamment les 35
heures
il espère que la france ne soit pas l'un
des pays d'europe où l'on travaille le
moins longtemps notamment vous avez
parlé de cela
j'aimerais revenir sur le faite vous
disait que les français souhaitent un
changement mais comment expliquer alors
que selon un sondage est là-bas parus
ces derniers temps 57% des français
souhaitaient qu edouard philippe reste à
matignon même si 52% des français selon
ce même sondage souhaitait un changement
de cap c'est assez paradoxal non oui
c'est paradoxal et ça montre bien qu'on
est en pleine crise et que on a besoin
de plus de démocratie
aujourd'hui on sent que le peuple est
écarté et des canaris contraire et
donnait finalement emmanuel macron le
fait que ce qu'il entend on voit avec la
convention citoyenne qui l'avait déjà je
vous rappeler appelé à dire qu'il n'y
aurait aucun filtre que elle pourrait
proposer tout ce qu'elle voudrait et on
voit déjà que eh ben elle est dépassée
et que tout les dires les mesures les
plus ambitieuses sont déjà mises de côté
donc les avis contraire il se rend les
balais ils les enterre on voit aussi
avec les soignants qui pendant
confinement devait être applaudi et a
été même applaudi par les députés en
marche
l'hypocrisie est aujourd'hui dévoilée
puisque mais les soignants eux aussi
sont écartés haineux et n'ont que des
cacahuètes et rien de plus
et massa à chaque fois la même chose et
je crois que aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'une vraie démocratie on a besoin d'une
politique qui doit se remettre en
question et au problème c'est que
emmanuel macron n'est pas capable de se
remettre en question on en a besoin on a
besoin de se dire est ce que la
croissance est ce que le modèle qu'on
nous vend est ce que le marché où tout
s'échange et tout se vend et le bon
modèle et où est ce qu il ne faut pas
plutôt aller vers autre chose
on voit qu'on est effectivement
récession c'est le temps de questionner
notre système il est urgent de se
questionner parce que devant nous on a
une crise écologique et c'est pas une
suggestion c'est une on est obligé de
2,6 et de s'y confronter c'est pas des
petites mesurettes qui vont nous faire
changer le cap
il faut qu'on change de 4 il faut qu'on
s'interroge profondément et
malheureusement il
le maquereau en est incapable justement
vous parlez de l'écologie à une vague
verte aux dernières municipales
est ce qu'il ya un profil écologistes à
matignon est envisageable que qu'est-ce
que la france
insoumise qu'on serait de cela par
exemple c'est n'importe quoi c'est
pascal canfin était promu premier
ministre dans l'écologie il y a deux
choses il n'y a bien que je
d'écologistes qui disent que le marché
est totalement compatible avec
l'écologie
et il y en a d'autres qui disent que non
il faut sortir de ça je pense que la
ligne
elle est là pascal canfin on sait très
bien de quel côté est l'écologie pour
lui c'est du jardinage rien plus de lens
tubes y en a également qui circulent
régulièrement
qu'en pensez vous c'est pareil ce qu'on
pense c'est qu'il faut vraiment ce qu'on
a proposé à la france un soumises pour
être très concret c'est la règle verte
la règle verte c'est de dire on peut pas
prendre plus à la nature que ce qu'elle
est en capacité de régénérer ça veut
dire que toutes les activités doit être
vue sous ce prisme
tout est donc quand on voit ça aime on
voit qu'on peut pas signer un certain
quand on prend ça on voit que on peut
pas prolonger le glyphosate quand on
voit ça un peu on peut pas accorder
d'aidé d exploitation est la montagne
d'or en guyane un bref vous voyez que
quand on met cette règle cela règle
verte au dessus de tout vous voyez donc
à la fonte d'un soumises et plus
légitime en terme d'écologie qu'europe
écologie les verts par exemple
non je pense que l'écologie c'est un
profond changement de système et que là
dedans il y a des tartuffes qui pensent
que le marché est compatible avec
l'écologie et qui en a d'autres qui sont
prêts à revoir complètement le logiciel
parce qu'il n'ya que en revoyant
complètement le logiciel qu'on pourra
vraiment faire de l'écologie en dehors
de ça c'est du jardinage
qu'est ce que vous attendez du prochain
remaniement ministériel en terme général
puisqu'on
beaucoup parlé d' edouard philippe mais
c'est la démission du gouvernement ce
qui implique donc des portefeuilles
ministériels qui vont être vacant on
pense notamment à christophe castaner à
l'intérieur qu'est ce que vous attendez
à ce que vous vous auriez des noms à
citer si par exemple vous vous seriez
appelé ce que vous diriez oui et que
feriez vous je pense que vous savez très
bien que personne de la france insoumise
n'acceptera quoi que ce soit emmanuel
macron n'essaiera même pas d'ailleurs
parce que toute façon nous ne sommes pas
du tout dans le même logiciel que lui je
pense qu'il peut juste faire confiance à
des opportunistes et c'est tout en tout
cas moi je l'attends absolument rien de
ce remaniement
je suis lucide et je pense que les
français le sont aussi on voit comment
il a il a traité à chaque contestation
qui a été dans la rue et ça fait des
années que ça dure
malheureusement il n'y a rien à attendre
de sa part rapport la communication de
l'elysée de matignon le fait d'annoncer
cette démission ce matin qu'est-ce que
ça traduisent selon vous ça traduit
surtout qu'ils n'ont pas grand chose a
commenté parce que malheureusement il ya
d'autres réalités en ce moment dans
notre pays
saleh jeu j'ai fait la liste de tous les
licenciements qui sont annoncées et je
peux vous dire que c'est terrifiant
absolument terrifiant il ya sanofi et
bien boire auliac at-elle il ya 1 h 9
alinéa la halle qui compte pour déjà
quinze licenciements camaïeu celio
là on en est déjà à presque dix mille
encore renault et air france easyjet tu
nokia boeing etc la liste est tellement
longue et tout ça ça se compte en
milliers de licenciements c'est de ça
dont on devrait parler c'est ça
l'urgence c'est qu'aujourd'hui en france
on a des gens qui vont crever de faim
c'est ça on a des gens qui sont mis sur
le côté on a des et puis rien n'y fait
aussi pour nos jalons voit que les
fermetures de classes on se prolonger à
la rentrée c'est ça la vraie urgence
pourquoi est ce qu'on n'en parle pas
c'est ça qui devrait faire les gros
titres et par edouard philippe qui va au
avons tous font finalement parce que
qu'est ce qui inquiète aujourd'hui les
français ce qui les inquiète c'est de
pouvoir remplir leurs oeufs leur frigo à
la fin du mois ce qui les inquiète c'est
de ne pas pouvoir perdre leur travail
ce qui les inquiète c'est de pouvoir en
trouver un et ils ne pourront pas ce qui
les inquiète c'est que aujourd'hui
la formation professionnelle c'est plus
compliqué d'avoir accès à la formation
professionnelle que de prendre un crédit
à la banque c'est ça la réalité
aujourd'hui et malheureusement on n'en
parle pas et sait et c'est pour ça que
les il ya une vraie crise démocratique
et le remaniement là dedans c'est une
goutte d'eau ça sert à rien c'est du
vent c'est la communication des manuels
macron merci jeudi dernier c'est mot de
la fin je rappelle que vous êtes
oratrice de la france insoumise